[Music]
mr. president seated before you are the
trustees faculty alumni candidates for
degrees and honored guests of the
university assembled for the annual
commencement in Columbia's 260 third
academic year
with your permission mr. president the
exercises will now begin please stand
for the vocal performance of the
national anthem by D tau School of
Professional Studies class of 2017 oh
[Applause]
say can you see by the dawn's early
light what so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and bright stars through the
perilous night or the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly streaming and
the Rockets red glare the bombs bursting
air gave proof through the night that
our flag was still there oh say does
that star-spangled banner yet wave
or the land of the free and the whole
brain
[Applause]
the opening words will be pronounced by
Janel Davis University chaplain
congratulations
Columbia University 2017 graduates your
Columbia University degree will identify
you around the globe as among the best
educated women and men in the world
graduates challenges and opportunities
are expanding for people who are brave
courageous people of good character and
good will at Columbia University alumni
you will have opportunities and
responsibilities to address the most
critical local national and global
issues of our time you will give give
guidance on matters of international
affairs public policy business
engineering architecture the art
the humanities the social and the
Natural Sciences you will give counsel
on matters of law data science economics
sustainable development the environment
climate change human rights Social Work
education new media and journalism you
will be on the vanguard of public health
research and neuroscience dentistry
nursing and medicine you will write our
story make our film and delight our
souls with dance music and theater you
will give voice voice to the common good
the common good of us all may you enjoy
the blessings of lifelong learning the
demands of reasons optimism and the joys
of daring dreams stay brave stay brave
may it be so maybe so
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the university Li si Bohlander on behalf
of the trustees and the Faculty of
Columbia University it is my very great
pleasure and honor to welcome all of you
to this ceremony to celebrate the class
of 2017 it is our tradition together
in this magnificent setting surrounding
alma mater to affirm the knowledge
acquired by our extraordinary students
and to recognize their remarkable
achievements you represent 16 schools
along with our affiliate institutions
Teachers College and Barnard
[Applause]
all of you all of you
[Music]
[Applause]
all of you are now intellectually and
loyally connected to those who have been
here before you over the past 263 years
and to those who will follow you for
centuries to come this day is all about
the graduates and what you've earned
earned
[Music]
earn through endless and mostly foggy
hours of study earn by overcoming again
and again your natural inclination for
procrastination living by the principle
of just-in-time which means waiting
until the last moment to study for exams
and write papers earned through
sacrifice of something we call sleep not
to mention nutrition and personal
hygiene and earn by persevering in those
inevitable moments of self-doubt
now while this occasion is about you
there are a few people here today who
have contributed mightily to your
getting to this point in life and whom
you'll never be able to thank enough I
can assure you that nothing focuses the
mind like the successes and
disappointments of one's own children
and as much as we your faculty feel deep
affection for you nothing can compare to
the pure adoration of your parents and
families please take this opportunity to
thank
[Applause]
because a graduation signifies such an
important moment of achievement and
transition in life
it leaves a deep impression on our minds
we also tend to remember vividly the
events that were occurring in the world
at the time it is common to hear people
say I graduated when such-and-such
happened sometimes what is recounted is
fairly momentous usually less so for
those of us here today I doubt that we
will ever have trouble remembering what
is happening in the world now or the
seriousness of the events coalescing in
2017 just how significant a turning
point in world history this will be
remains to be seen but there appears
little reason to doubt that this nation
and much of the broader world is at an
historic juncture some see ominous
horizons while others see reason for
hope we read in here daily here and
abroad about the rise of populist
movements all rooted in nationalist
impulses resistant to the continuation
of globalization and multilateralism in
its many forms economic trade political
the European Union communications the
internet movements of people the
refugees often this results in the rise
and embrace of authoritarian figures for
many as I said this represents a
foreboding reality for others it carries
the promise of bringing discipline to
growing disorder and awakening stagnant
political and social systems desperately
in need of fresh ways of thinking I
believe passionately that we need new
and better ways to address the myriad
challenges they
seen our country in the world but for
what it's worth I share the first
perspective viewing these developments
with profound concern most of the
debates taking place right now are about
changes to particular policies health
care tax reform immigration national
security but as is always true the most
important changes are and will be to the
character of our deliberative process
the nature of the public forum and our
capacity for self-government you don't
need to be a free speech expert to know
the following fundamental truth in the
end we as individuals or as a society or
international community are what we
think what we speak and how we interact
with one another the outcomes of our
public discourse while important follow
rather than lead the life we live so it
is right to ask I think what is
happening to our collective thinking
into the public forum in this new era my
answer is that what is happening is not
good and it's actually very dangerous
there are many things I could focus on
here but one concern I would single out
is how the new politics are
characterizing and demonizing all things
for it there are a host of perfectly
legitimate differences
there are hosts of perfectly legitimate
differences of opinion and responses
when it comes to how to address major
challenges like climate change
international trade terrorism the
integrity of national elections or
privacy and hate speech in the digital
age the problem however is not with the
fact that there are many hard questions
or a vigorous debate about them but with
the emergence of and stoking of a state
of anger and fear surrounding them
genuine issues always undergird and help
to mask the mental condition of fear but
when it arises it introduces a very
threatening element into our debates and
our world I know it is too much to
expect of political discourse that it
mimic the measured self-questioning
rational footnoting standards of the
academy but there is a difference
between robust political debate and
political debate infected with fear or
panic
the latter introduces a state of mind
that is visceral and irrational in the
realm of fear we move beyond the reach
of reason and a sense of proportionality
when we fear we lose the capacity to
listen and we can become insensitive and
mean our Constitution is well aware of
this fact about the human mind and its
negative political consequences in the
First Amendment jurisprudence
established over the past century we
find many expressions of the problematic
State of Mind of fear among the most
famous and potent that of Justice
Brandeis in Whitney vs. California in
one of the many cases involving
aggravated fears of subversive threats
from abroad quote it is the function of
free speech Brandeis said to free men
people from the bondage of irrational
fears men feared witches brand I'd
continued and burned women today our
witches are terrorists and brand Isis
metaphorical women include the refugees
mostly children and displaced persons
immigrants whose lives have been thrown
into suspension and doubt whose lives
have been thrown into suspension and
doubt by policies of exclusion there are
many reasons to oppose these policies
but one in particular strikes at the
heart of our intellectual life and is
best expressed by the mission of
universities namely that we should avoid
if at all possible heedlessly erecting
walls intellectual walls that will
impair that will impair our ability to
understand and engage our modern
interconnected world for the world today
is imbued with profound issues and needs
that however much we might wish
otherwise simply are not going away that
no wall can block and that deserve as
much attention and thought as our
collective minds can possibly muster
Columbia University by our history our
location and through our active and
ongoing efforts has embraced the
responsibility to be an American
University with an international scope
at home not just
at home not just in this great city but
in the world we are properly proud of
our international students and faculty
and of our and of our research and
educational work all over the globe the
free movement of people is vital to that
edge intellectual work there are still
greater dangers that will come with
abandoning this path and with
accommodating the policies and
underlying attitudes here and around the
world that would lead us to withdraw
from the global marketplace of ideas it
is a distressing fact of human
experience that persecution of the quote
foreign is part and parcel of rising
intolerance at home the same fears of
the foreign that take hold of a popular
population
inevitably infect our internal
interactions and institutions yielding
suppression of unpopular and dissenting
voices victimization of vulnerable
groups attacks on the media and the rise
of demagoguery and the rise of
demagoguery with its disdain for facts
and reason expertise intolerance the
most infamous and shameful historical
periods in which we departed from our
core First Amendment principles of
Liberty and thought of thought and
expression always involved a combination
of the two strains of intolerance the
foreign and the domestic this was true
at the nation's inception with the
revealingly named alien and
act of 1798 continued on to the last
century with the notorious Red Scare
following the first world war and
persisted in the McCarthy era following
the Second World War both of which
interestingly involved national paranoia
and panic over efforts by the Russians
to undermine American democracy all of
this poses a very special obligation on
those of us within universities not only
what must we make the case in every
venue for the values that form the core
of what we do and what we are but we
must also live up to our own principles
of free inquiry and fearless engagement
with all ideas this is why recent
incidents on a handful of college
campuses disrupting and effectively
censoring speakers is so alarming such
acts such acts not only betray a basic
principle but also inflame a rising
prejudice against the academic community
and feed efforts to delegitimize our
work at the very moment when it is most
needed I do not for a second support the
view that this generation has an
unhealthy aversion to engaging
differences of opinion that is a modern
trope of polarization as is the
portrayal of universities as
hypocritical about academic freedom and
political correctness but now in this
environment especially universities must
be at the forefront of defending the
rights of all students and faculty to
listen to controversial voices to engage
disagreeable viewpoints
and to make every effort to demonstrate
our commitment to the sort of fearless
and spirited debate that we are
simultaneously asking of the larger
society anyone with a voice can shout
over a speaker but being able to listen
to and then effectively rebut those with
whom we disagree particularly those who
themselves peddle intolerance is one of
the greatest skills our education can
bestowed and it is something that our
democracy desperately needs more of that
is why I say to you now if speakers who
are being denied access to other
campuses were to come here I will
personally volunteer to introduce them
and listen to them however much I may
disagree with them
but I will also never hesitate to make
clear why I disagree with them this is a
time above all for active engagement
that of course means you when you leave
here and the rest of us who stay to be
with your successes but I also believe
that universities now need to rethink
their role in society and consider new
ways to apply the extraordinary
knowledge and capacities we possess to
activities that will improve the human
condition
and help to solve humanity's problems
our special role as a University of
course is to expand knowledge and to
educate the next generation and to do
that we must be careful not to take
political sides but even with that
injunction in mind there is plenty of
room for universities to be far more
engaged than we have been many faculty
members already find ways to do this on
their own but no university has adopted
as a central mission the project of
working closely with partners beyond the
Academy in government the private sector
and civil society who have the power
influence and relationships to transform
the intellectual work into solutions so
urgently needed in the larger world and
as you know Columbia is now planning to
embark on that very mission through the
new Columbia world projects whether it
be through climate monitoring and
seasonal forecasting aimed at mitigating
the effects of climate change on public
health food security and global
migration or by making the coming
revolution in health care based on
precision medicines use of genetic
sequencing making it available to the
largest number of people there are many
areas where Columbia can be more
actively involved in helping out with
some of the world's greatest needs
I hope in the years to come you will
look back with pride on what Columbia
has done in traditional and in new ways
to help make your world in our world
better so I conclude where I began by
noting the pervasive sense that society
is at an historic juncture each of us
will have our own views about the proper
resolution of issues now dominating the
public's attention and even more
significantly about the populist tides
we are witnessing this much though
should be clear as you take stock of
this auspicious moment in your own life
the way you think and speak and engage
those who will be your partners in
charting the future will count for
everything for our collective efforts
for our collective effort efforts to
rehabilitate public discourse a
discourse that is being profoundly
threatened by fear and intolerance
ultimately will have a tremendous impact
in shaping the world we and most
importantly you will live in if you
succeed in that project in rejecting
that fear and engaging with the world in
all its complexity as you have done in
your time here at Columbia then the
promising and essential work commencing
here at your alma mater will I am
certain have its intended effect I wish
you the greatest good luck as you take
up this considerable challenge and begin
the next part of your amazing life
congratulations
[Applause]
the Provost of the University John H
cotesworth will present the candidate
for the university medal for excellence
and candidates for degrees in honoris
causa please hold your applause until
all citations have been read mr.
president I have the honor to present
Julia Basha for the University medal of
excellence
[Applause]
[Music]
giulia Basha you are a rare individual a
Brazilian born woman who attended
Colombia's school of general studies and
found her calling as a documentary
filmmaker immersed in the conflicts of
the Middle East your filmmaking tells
the stories of individuals who reach
across religious and political divides
choosing the path of non-violence to
accept to affect change these sensitive
documentaries on the israeli-palestinian
conflict expand our understanding of
that ongoing struggle and through them
we learn about what the human spirit can
achieve in the face of despair and
division for the remarkable films you
already have given us and for those you
will create in the future we proudly
present to you with the medal of
excellence of the University
congratulations Julia bus
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present chuck de pan as a recipient of
the degree of Doctor of Humane Letters
jacques pepin in a world where many
aspire to such status you are a genuine
culinary icon a groundbreaking chef who
democratized the art of cooking and in
so doing remade the modern American
kitchen your gift to our nation's home
cooks was nothing less than sharing the
skills needed to experience the profound
joy of a simple meal well-prepared a
personal chef - three heads of state you
chose to engage the public rather than
remain ensconced in the Executive
Mansion the secrets of a life well-lived
are among the most elusive of teaching
[Music]
for offering us that guidance and more
Columbia is proud to present you with
the degree of Doctor of Humane Letters
honoris causa congratulations chocolate
[Applause]
mr. president I now have the honor to
present Eric H holder as a recipient of
the Eric H holder Jr for six years as a
history-making US Attorney General
you provided a shining example for the
nation your character and values were
revealed by the causes you champion so
effectively the prosecution of hate
crimes reform of the criminal justice
system support support for the right of
same-sex couples to marry and the full
throated rejection of new encroachments
on the right to vote
[Applause]
we look on with pride and admiration as
you an alumnus of Columbia College and
the law school shouldered this
responsibility with remarkable grace and
valor for your courage your grit and
your determination to protect the
liberty and security of all Americans
Columbia is proud to present you with
the degree of Doctor of Laws honoris
causa congratulations Eric
[Applause]
as president I have the honor to present
Admiral Michael Mullen for the degree of
Doctor of Laws honoris causa Admiral
Michael Mullen as chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff you served two
presidents with distinction and valor
you used your authority to seek repeal
of Don't Ask Don't Tell recognizing that
a policy of institutionalized dishonesty
was beneath the dignity of America and
its armed forces the United States
military the nation and the world know
you to be a leader of the highest
caliber one who speaks with quiet candor
and acts with unimpeachable integrity at
this university particularly among our
thriving community of student veterans
and reservists you will forever be
remembered for healing the half-century
old rift between higher education and
the military and for being our partner
in returning the naval ROTC to Columbia
for your service your sacrifice and your
courage Columbia is proud to present you
with the degree of Doctor of Laws
honoris causa congratulations Michael
Miller
mr. president I have the honor to
present Padma Desai for the degree of
Doctor of Letters honoris causa
[Applause]
Padma Desai legendary economist global
policymaker and cherish Columbia
professor your contributions have left
indelible marks on the fields of
emerging markets and comparative
economic systems while at the same time
elevating the well-being of societies
around the world you are a global
citizen and scholar deeply curious about
different cultures ideologies and people
from proposing an economic plan for the
post-communist Soviet state to guiding
India's journey to a more market-based
economy your work and its impact have
been unconstrained by time and place you
also are grateful we also are grateful
that you have shared your wisdom about
life's journey in two beautiful and
deeply revealing memoirs for succeeding
so extravagantly in all of these noble
pursuits we are proud to award you the
degree of Doctor of Letters honoris
causa congratulations
cognitive science
okay award we need to put a hood on mr.
president mr. Paulo since my young
friend I was born in the back waters of
India I came here 60 years ago America
is a great country do not believe if
others say anything else I want you to
go out see the wide world how people
live on a dollar a day come back and if
you join Wall Street and make your
millions give a million to Columbia
University on that way
[Applause]
sure
not just a million mr. president I have
the honor to present Martin du bourbon
for the degree of Doctor of Letters
Honorius Calculon
[Applause]
Martin Duberman few historians and
indeed few contemporary scholars have
more powerfully demonstrated the role of
the intellectual in forging social
progress your award-winning political
plays exploring the devastating personal
impact of repression and your biography
of brilliant outsiders including Paul
Robeson and Lincoln Kersting have
inspired many as has your candid
nonfiction demanding that gays lesbians
and other minorities be freed from
establishment stereotypes and
constraints for you action always
followed in sight
you were the founding director of the
Center for lesbian and gay Studies at
the Graduate Center of the City
University of New York and helped to
build the gay academic union for leading
societies marched for the towards
equality with unwavering dedication
Columbia presents you with a degree of
Doctor of Letters honoris causa
congratulations Martin Buber
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
acknowledge Joe Alberto Bravo Ferrera
aioli vada for the degree of Doctor of
music honoris causa is Wow Gilberto
could not be with us today
to whom lovers of music the world over
will forever be indebted due to his
invention of bossa nova we are proud to
award him an honorary degree but
unfortunately he is not able to be with
us this morning
with revolutionary guitar playing and a
groundbreaking singing style he produced
a new sound and a rich collection of
songs as evocative as they were
instantly recognizable few modern
artists can match his creativity or the
lasting impact of his music fewer still
can claim to have introduced the world
to something elemental about a nation
soul and its spirit he is Brazil's
global ambassador of musical culture
university students have always been
among his most devoted admirers and they
remain so today for uniting the people
around the globe through his beautiful
and timeless music we present draaga
Berto with the degree of Doctor of music
honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Alan Irwin Hyman for the degree
of Doctor of Science honoris causa dr.
Alan I Hyman your achievements in
anesthesiology and neonatal care are
matched in equal measure by your
exceptional service to this University
as head of Columbia Presbyterian Medical
Center's neonatal intensive care unit
your innovation saved the lives of
multitudes of premature newborns
suffering from respiratory distress
syndrome in ten years time a 90%
mortality rate was replaced with a 90%
survival rate our College of Physicians
and Surgeons will forever be grateful
for your dedication to training aspiring
doctors Columbia College counts you
among its most cherished alumni
[Music]
[Applause]
for all you have done for our students
or your patients their families and the
medical profession we are proud to
present you with the degree of Doctor of
Science honoris causa congratulations
Allen Hyman the president of the
University will present the awards for
excellence in teaching the professors
will stand as their names are announced
please hold your applause until all
recipients have been recognized with
deepest admiration we recognize these
professors selected by the campus
community for this honor for their
sustained excellence in teaching and
their remarkable dedication to the
intellectual development of their
students
these abates assistant professor of
epidemic at the DB ology Jamis khan
associate professor of sociology
Sara nuki life compressor - Bernstein
associate clinical professor of human
rights Erin Matthew Kyle senior lecturer
and biomedical engineering design and
Tian Jing associate professor of
statistics congratulations and thank you
the president of the university will
present the 2017 alumni medalists the
alumni will stand as their names are
announced please hold your applause
until all recipients have been
recognized just as you did this last
time the Alumni medal is the highest
award bestowed by the Columbia Alumni
Association in recognition of
distinguished service and commitment to
the University I am pleased to recognize
the 2017 alumni medal recipients for
their extraordinary dedication to
Columbia Anthony and jello Tango knee
the Foo Foundation School of Engineering
and Applied Science in Columbia Business
School
Michael Kornfeld Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences Kathleen and Crowley
mailman School of Public Health
Emily ball Jabbar School of Social Work
Steven Michael Kane Columbia College and
Columbia Law School Peter Marber School
of International and public affairs
Matthew C Romney Columbia School of
Nursing
Martha C Romney Francis Sadler Barnard
College and teachers
and head coach cheek Satoshi Tanaka the
Foo Foundation School of Engineering and
Applied Science and lastly Sheri Panzer
wolf Columbia College he readily and now
a message of congratulations from the
chair of the Columbia Alumni Association
Brian Chris Berg good morning class of
2017 my name is Brian Chris Berg
Columbia College class of 1981 Columbia
Law School class of 1984 and I am
especially proud today to say that I am
a parent of a graduating Columbia
College senior as chair of the Columbia
Alumni Association or the shortened
version CIA it is my privilege today to
congratulate you as you become alumni of
Columbia University our community is
comprised of over 330 thousand alumni in
the New York area across the United
States and around the globe the goal of
our community is to foster an
environment where our lumps are fiercely
loyal loyal to the schools you attended
while at Columbia and simultaneously
committed to the principle of we are one
Columbia the notion that we are all
passionate committed citizens of this
great University a few words about CAA
CAA is the University alumni community
at Columbia CAA supports the work of
each individual schools alumni community
and partners with the schools to create
opportunities for alumni of multiple
schools to come together CAA oversees a
network of over 100 Columbia
in cities around the world and a
fast-growing number of shared interest
groups each conducting engaging
programming I encourage you to contact
the Alumni leaders at the local club in
your city or a shared interest group
that appeals to you CAA also is creating
numerous avenues for our alumni to
connect through social media and online
networking as you move ahead with your
careers and lives you will be regularly
regularly provided with the means to
stay engaged with Columbia I encourage
you to seek ways to do that as I have
done for the past quarter century so my
great enjoyment and personal fulfillment
in closing I extend my best wishes to
the fabulous class of 2017 and ask that
for those of you who know the words join
me in the following short refrain
written in 1993 excuse me 1923 sorry
roar lion roar and wake the echoes of
the Hudson Valley fight on to victory
evermore while the sons of Knickerbocker
rally round Columbia Columbia shouting
her name forever roar lion roar for alma
mater on the Hudson Shore thank you
[Applause]
the Provost of the University will
present the administrative officers of
the various divisions of the university
who will in turn introduce candidates
for the degrees in course in their
respective groups those candidates will
be expected to rise as they are being
introduced mr. president
it is my pleasure to present James J
Valentini Dean of Columbia College
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president before you appear the 1172
candidates for the degree of Bachelor of
Arts in Columbia College who are
celebrating not only their own
graduation but the 30th anniversary of
the first fully co-educational
graduating class of Home Depot they have
completed each and every one of the
requirements prescribed by the Faculty
of Columbia College for that degree and
have encyclopedic knowledge in all
fields of human endeavor they know that
30 is the smallest spheric number and
that 30 is the atomic number of zinc
they can identify all 30 of Bach's
Goldberg Variations and know why 30 is
the minimum age for US senators they
understand the causes of the 30 Years
War and they can explain the 30-second
shot clock in college basketball and
they know that their college was already
30 years old when its name was changed
from King's College to Columbia College
in 1784 given this knowledge I beg you
sir to grant them this degree along with
the rights and privileges thereto
attached
the prison
this president it is my pleasure to
present Mary C Boyce Dean of the Pooh
Foundation School
[Applause]
mr. president before you stand the
amazingly creative inventive innovative
and entrepreneurial candidates of the
Faculty of the Sioux Foundation School
of Engineering and Applied Science the
C's class of 2017 these men and women
are engineers and applied scientists who
will take on the grand challenges that
confront humanity and will push forward
disciplinary frontiers to create the
world of tomorrow these individuals have
each been uniquely amplified by their
Columbia experience to become engineers
for Humanity they turn waste into useful
products they capture co2 they invent
neonatal health care for low resource
areas they store data on DNA they create
cameras that flex and stretch to image
our world they make power grids and
infrastructure more secure and
sustainable these hammer waving Tanner
waving socially responsible engineers
and applied scientist who stand before
you today are not artificially
intelligent
[Music]
they are chemically reactive
mathematically determined
physically limitless biomedically in
hand
similarly sustainable computer-animated
electrically empowered data-driven
environmentally responsive industrially
ingenious financially engineered
mechanically amplified materially
inventive and operationally amplified
each of these candidates have completed
the rigorous requirements for the
degrees of Bachelor of Science Master of
Science Master of Philosophy
professional degree Doctor of
engineering science and Doctor of
Philosophy as prescribed by the Faculty
of the few Foundation School of
Engineering and Applied Science I urge
you sir to grant them their degrees the
world
[Applause]
the president it is my pleasure to
present Robert Goldberg interim
president of armor
[Applause]
I'm here yeah
mr. president it is my honor to present
you the brilliance the confidence and
the never complacent Barnard College
class of 2017 this incredible these
incredible Barnard women have
successfully completed a rigorous
academic program have made their College
a better place over the past four years
they have reacted to the past mastered
nine ways of knowing eating breakfast at
midnight deciphered analytic geometry
and devoured medieval history one
Fulbright's and Truman's intern from the
Bronx to the battery and brittish's of
empowerment Environment and equity to
the top of the agenda the bar in our
class of 2017 is prepared to enter a
world that calls for their creativity
their activism and yes their persistence
they are more than ready to meet the
challenges of tomorrow and I can assure
you sir their voices will be heard
mr. president these Barnard women have
completed the requirements prescribed by
the faculty for the Bachelor of Arts
degree I asked you that you please grant
them this degree along with the rights
and privileges thereto attached
the prison
it is my pleasure
to present Peter J on being in the
school of general studies
[Music]
mr. president mm mr. president
to your right and perched on Olympian
Heights stands a pantheon a brilliant
candidates of the Faculty of the school
of general studies a unique liberal arts
college at an Ivy League university
celebrating its 70th anniversary year
among the 585 stellar graduates 35
percent of whom are international
students or new Americans we are proud
to count 102 veterans of the US Armed
Forces the largest cohort since World
War two
at any Ivy League university or private
selective college we have more dancers
than the city ballet world travelers
single parents entrepreneurs graduates
of our dual and joint v8 programs with
young flow with the City University of
Hong Kong and the Jewish Theological
Seminary all of our graduates er are
deeply indebted
[Laughter]
deeply indebted to the faculty for their
superb education these exceptional women
and men have completed the requirements
prescribed by their faculty for the
degree of Bachelor of Arts I beg you sir
please grant them this degree along with
the rights and privileges thereto
attached thank you
[Applause]
the president
it is now my pleasure to present jason
wyngarde Dean of the School of
Professional Studies
[Applause]
mr. president before you stand the
exceptional focused adaptable marketable
and bright candidates of the Faculty of
Professional Studies these candidates
are earning degrees across 14
professional disciplines the unite the
unifying characteristics of this class
are an unquenchable thirst for
continuous applied learning an
undeniable quest to be leaders and
agents of change in their respective
fields and an uncommon readiness profile
for the market demands of tomorrow this
class includes future innovators just
beginning their professional journey
senior managers pivoting to new and
emerging fields of practice and industry
executives advancing to the c-suite each
upholds the tradition of highest order
excellence proudly representing Columbia
University mr. president these
candidates have completed the
requirements prescribed by the faculty
for the degree of Master of Science I
beg you sir to grant them this debris
along with the rights and privileges
thereto attached
[Applause]
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present to you Carol Becker Dean of the
School of the Arts we're small but we're
noisy mr. president over there
predictably on the extreme left stand
the wildly talented candidates of the
Faculty of the School of the Arts in
film theater visual arts and writing
they have come to us from most parts of
the United States as well as 41 of the
countries they are indisputably creative
hip savvy talented fashionable and most
of all resourceful
they've won many awards presented
screens displayed performed and
published their work in esteemed venues
throughout the city and the world and
while accomplishing all this they have
miraculously completed the requirements
described by the faculty for the degrees
of Master of Arts and Master of Fine
Arts mr. president these artists are so
very ready to leave us for the
understandably very exciting and
challenging worlds of Hollywood
Sundance Broadway the Brooklyn Academy
of Music the Museum of Modern Art and
the New York Times
seller list julie has there ever been a
time when art and culture and all the
imagination and hope they can Bay have
been more needed than now so mr.
president you really should let them go
I promise you they are fearless they
will take on the problems of the world
in uniquely powerful ways and they will
make us very proud Thank You mr.
president it is my pleasure to present
merit II J now Dean of the School of
International and public affairs
[Applause]
mr. president before you send the
candidates of the Faculty of
International and public affairs who
have completed the requirements for the
degrees of Master of International
Affairs and Master of Public
Administration they come from 78
countries they are worldly dedicated
civic minded entrepreneurial and
globally engaged analysts and problem
solvers they are imbued with a mission
of SEPA to lead and serve in the global
public interest they will soon change
the world and we need them to play a
leadership role as policymakers business
leaders stewards of the environment and
humanitarian causes as security
professionals bankers ambassadors future
mayors governors ministers and heads of
state their influence will be and their
fidelity will be both global and local
and I ask you sir to grant them these
degrees with all of the rights and
privileges thereto attached
[Applause]
this president
it is now my pleasure to present to you
Aaron Garfinkel interim dean of the
School of Social Work
[Applause]
mr. president before you stand the
candidates of the Faculty of Social Work
who have completed the requirements
prescribed by that faculty for the
degree of Master of Science they are an
accomplished group they are prepared to
go and do social work at every level
helping individuals one at a time
changing social policy to make it
possible for individuals to survive and
thrive
I beg you serve to grant them this
degree along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached
[Music]
[Applause]
the President shall my pleasure to
present to you Christiane F Stoller Dean
of the College of Dental Medicine
[Applause]
mr. president I present to you 76
exquisitely skilled candidates of the
Doctor of Dental Surgery program and 45
men and women of the advanced dental
specialties they know how to run a fast
will operate a really sharp knife and
play around with very nasty instruments
that they allow you to do things that
you mr. president do not want to know
they can handle incisors canines
premolars molars tongue and cheek comes
and bones and much more the faculty
informs me that they are now running
circles around them and therefore mr.
president in agreement with the
recommendation of the Faculty of the
College of Dental Medicine celebrating
its 100th anniversary on University Line
in this year I rectal I urge you mr.
president
I beg you mr. president to confer upon
these candidates the degree Doctor of
Dental Surgery and the applicable degree
for the advanced specialties
this prisoner
it is now my pleasure because then our
Glenn Hubbard ena the Columbia business
mr. president mr. president before you
stand the entrepreneurial the
opportunity ready candidates of the
Faculty of business
Kate stock of my Bond sir accept my
warrant look on with interest they have
completed the ridiculously hard
requirements prescribed by the faculty
for the degrees of Master of Business
Administration and Master of Science I
beg you sir beseech you to grant these
young dividends the degrees along with
the rights and responsibilities thereto
attached
the president
it is now my pleasure to present Stephen
Cole Dean of the cult the fueler Germany
it's the president
mr. president
according to the New York Times the
President of the United States recently
suggested to the Director of the FBI
that he send journalists to prison if
they disclose classified information in
a sign of the times this was only the
third most interesting story to come out
of Washington in the last 48 hours as
you have pointed out there can be no
doubt that journalism is under threat in
the United States and worldwide but I am
pleased mr. president to offer a
powerful response the Graduate School of
Journalism class of 2017
they have spent a hard harrowing year
internalizing the highest values of
their of their profession independence
courage persistence and investigative
skill they know now that a slug is not
only a mollusk they know it is better to
be right than first they are the
alternative to alternative facts
mr. president in light of their great
reliability I humbly request that you
grant these candidates the degrees of
Master of Science Master of Science in
computer science and journalism Master
of Arts and Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges thereto
attacks the president it is now my great
pleasure to present Susan H Furman
president of Teachers College mr.
president to your left
stand the candidates of the Faculty of
Teachers College who have completed the
requirements prescribed by the faculty
for the degrees of Master of Arts Master
of Education Master of Science and
Doctor of Education
I implore you sir to grant them these
degrees along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached they are
schools and schooling intense about
innovation revved up about reform
learning about leading change into
technology and above all yearnings for
learning thank you
the president is now my great pleasure
to present Amol andreas Dean of the
Graduate School of Architecture planning
and preservation mr. president before
you stand the candidates of the Faculty
of architecture planning and
preservation the G sub class of 2017 key
students are visionaries digital
pioneers makers products alone
entrepreneurs extraordinaire and
incurable idealist they are artists by
nature builders by trade and Urbanists
by conviction they are synthesizes
drawing together the scales of space and
time the local and the global the class
and the future they are alchemists who
render the invisible visible the
immaterial tangible the ordinary
extraordinary the urban natural and the
imagined real in their hands and mind is
the future of architecture of cities and
of the environment they have boldly
brilliantly and without any sleep
completed the requirements prescribed by
that faculty for the degrees of Master
of Architecture and Master of Science I
beg you sir to grant them these degrees
along with the rights and privileges
that you attach
miss president my pleasure to present
Julien Lester Dean of the Columbia Law
School mr. president here before you
stand the candidates who have completed
the requirements prescribed by the
faculty for the degrees of juris doctor
Master of Laws and Doctor of the science
of law today this new class of graduates
will join the distinguished rank of
Columbia Law School graduates some of
whom have been honored by this
University today who have shaped the
world as lawyers and leaders they are
ready to devote their lives to the
pursuit of justice to the defense of the
rule of law and to a finely crafted
argument the class of 2017 has enriched
the law school and the University and
they will make the world a better place
I placed before you sir a preponderance
of evidence of their achievement
and I assert that beyond a reasonable
doubt the only just decision is to grant
them these degrees along with the rights
and the privileges thereto attached
[Applause]
mr. president it's my pleasure to
present to you Lee Goldman executive
vice president and dean of the faculties
of health sciences and medicine and
chief executive of a Columbia University
Medical Center mr. president on behalf
of the Faculty of Columbia's College of
fabulous physicians and superb surgeons
I'm proud to present the candidates
who've been undaunted as they've
completed our version of the 3 R's
that's our ridiculously rigorous
requirements for master's or doctoral
degrees in given nutrition occupational
therapy physical therapy science and
medicine now I realize that they seem
young today but tomorrow we'll all be
relying on them we'll be relying on them
when do you need a careful physical
examination or get heatstroke at a
graduation
whether your diets not quite right or
you've got poor eyesight whether they've
gotten aching your back or an acute
heart attack even if you get cancer
they'll have the answer so it please mr.
president I beg for your consent granny
doesn't become a diploma before I slip
into a coma now mr. president as you
know this is the 250th anniversary of
the medical school the first medical
school in the venn colonies to grant the
MD degree as has been our custom for
these many years may we also request
your permission to administer the
Hippocratic oath to those to whom you
have just granted the Doctor of Medicine
degree now mr. president this year's
graduates are prepared to recite that
oath by heart in the original ancient
Greek but I beg your permission to allow
me to administer the oath to them and to
be joined by some of our distinguished
medical faculty who are also standing
for the students and graduates if you
swear to these things please bow your
head and a sign of acquiescence I
solemnly swear
but whatever hold most sacred that I
will be loyal to the profession of
medicine and Justin generous to its
members that I will lead my life and
practice my art in uprightness and honor
and into what soever house I shall enter
it shall be for the good of the sick to
the utmost of my power including myself
are aloof from wrong from corruption and
for the tempting of others device but
I'll exercise my art solely for the cure
of my patients that will give no drug no
perform no operation for an unworthy
purpose even if solicited far less
suggestive than whatsoever I shall see
or hear of the lives of my patients
which is not fitting to be spoken I will
keep enviable secret if you are true to
this oath may good repute ever be yours
the opposite the shall you prove
yourselves for sworn congratulations and
welcome to the profession of Medicine
this president it's my pleasure to
present to you Bobby Berkowitz Dean of
the School of Nursing mr. president
please meet a representative sample of
more than 350 candidates of the ninth of
the 2017 graduating class of the School
of Nursing
it's a school of nursing's 125th
birthday this year and our faculty
believe at that advanced age we have
that we have the expertise to produce
some of the best men and women in
nursing who are the next generation of
clinicians and scholars who will keep us
healthy manage our care should we become
ill and discover new ways to improve
quality of health care because our
health depends on them it is in your
best interest and all of us sir that you
grant the Master of Science Doctor of
Nursing science practice degrees along
with the rights and responsibilities and
privileges thereto attached
mr. president it's now my pleasure to
present Linda P freed Dean of the
Melbourne School of Public Health
[Applause]
mr. president before you with the
immensely loud voices stand the socially
committed relentlessly global human
focused politically astute diverse and
stupendously brilliant candidates of the
mailman School of Public Health sir
these candidates hailing from countries
across the globe deeply understands that
science knowledge evidence and health
are public goods that require their
leadership and our collective investment
for the success of societies they should
not be detained with this knowledge from
their noble mission of improving health
and preventing disease throughout the
world
these amazing students have completed
the requirements prescribed by their
faculty for the degrees of Master of
Public Health Master of Health
Administration Master of Science and
Doctor of Public Health
I beseech you sir to grant these 669
amazing people their degrees along with
the rights and responsibilities thereto
attached
[Applause]
this president it's my pleasure to
present Carlos J Alonso Dean of the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences mr.
president before you stand the
candidates of the Faculty of the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences who
have completed the requirements
prescribed by that faculty for the
degrees of Master of Arts Master of
Philosophy Doctor of Philosophy and
Doctor of Musical Arts sir I am aware
that as president you received great
Intel indeed you probably have people
brief you on great --into every day but
there are qualities about these
candidates that you may not know about
and which I will share with you as
required by the Kaenel beauty they have
come to dislike the adjective
interesting which seems to be the usual
response from their audience well
whether at a bar or at a family
gathering whenever they finish
explaining the research as in hmm
interesting they have realized to their
great chagrin that nobody really cares
as much as they do about the proper use
of the semicolon or is convinced as they
are that Congress should legislate to
impose its correct usage throughout the
land they have their own concept of time
and have grown accustomed to measuring
years not as 12 months but with a unit
called that semester for them the year
has only three seasons fall spring and
summer and summers are always too short
and fall and spring always feel like
they will never end
and finally at some point they became
convinced that they had mastered the
Jedi mind-trick because for many years
they were able to say to their relatives
and friends I'm almost done with my
thesis and the relatives would always
answer back
of course you're almost done with your
thesis but done they are sir and today
today they have their final vindication
because they will receive from you the
supreme degree that the academic world
has to offer I beseech you mr. president
to give them and their families and
friends occasion to rejoice by granting
them these degrees along with the rights
and privileges there to attach will all
candidates for degrees in course rise
for the conferring of degrees by the
president enough begging the appropriate
academic authorities have determined and
have so reported to me those students
who have successfully satisfactorily
completed the course of study prescribed
by the faculty under which they have
each been enrolled as a candidate for a
university degree in accordance with the
authority vested in me as president of
the University I now admit each of you
to the degree for which you have
qualified in token whereof you will
subsequently receive your diploma
congratulations class of 2005
[Applause]
please now rise and join the Columbia
Plateau hangers in the singing of stand
Columbia please remain standing for
closing words by the University
[Music]
Oh
return to Columbia often to challenge
your mind and to refresh your spirit
safe travels dot speed until the
academic recession has entered low
library guests of University and the
graduates are requested to remain in
their places